طبعا هذا نتنياهو يتحدث الان دمروا الشر
نتا
نيتا اود ان اتوجه
اليك ولكل العائلات
الك ابنك لم يقتل
سمع سوف نقضي على شر
حماس في 48
ساعه بون خ مقلو ق ضاريا خانون و عشرات
المخربين في شمال
القطاع دمروا منصات الاطلاق الصواريخ
وقتلوا مخربين اخرين واضافه الى ذلك في
الايام الاخيره
دمرنا منظومه
ضخمه تصنيع
الصواريخ وخلافا لكل الاشاعات الحرب
مستمره على كل الجبهات وتستمر على كل
الجبهات حتى نحقق كل الاهداف التي وضعناها
هذا هو ما
امرت به وهذا هو ما امر المستوى السياسي
للمستوى العسكري هذا هو قرار الحكومه
وامرها لكافه الاذرع الامنيه وسينفذ هذه
المهمه الملقاه على عاتقهم ومن اجل ذلك
قمنا بتمرير ميزانيه ضخمه تتيح للجيش
والاجهزه الامنيه ان تلتزم باهداف الحرب
وان تحقق
النصر والان ساقول بشكل واضح وبسيط الن
سيستغرق اشهر طويله ولكننا عازمون على
تحقيقه وهناك امر
اخر امر
صعب في الوقت الذي فيه يضحي مقاتلون من
اجل تحقيق النصر على
حماس اسمعوا اصوات اخرى
تحاول تدعي في استديوهات التلفزه انه لا
يمكننا الانتصار وانا انفي ذلك جمله
وتفصيلا اسرائيل قيادتي لن تتنازل عن
تحقيق نصر مؤزر على حماس ونحن نحقق هذا
النصر واقول
هذا مجددا كي لا يشكك احد بالكلام نحن
ذاهبون باتجاه نصر مؤزر ليس فقط ضربه
حماس ليس فقط الاضرار
بحماس ليس فقط وانما ان نحقق نصرا ساحقا
على
حماس سنواصل القتال بكل قوه حتى حقق كل
اهدافنا اعاده المختطفين
واقول فقط الضغط العسكري سيؤدي الى ذلك
والقضاء على
حماس ونضمن ان لا تشكل غزه اي تهديد على
اسرائيل وان لا يكون فيها اي جهه تمول
الارهاب وتدعم الارهاب وترسل الارهابيين
الينا ان وقف الحرب قبل تحقيق اهدافنا سوف
تضر بمكانه
اسرائيل اجيالا كثيره قادمه هذا مهم ليس
فقط لامنا اليوم بل ايضا امننا في
المستقبل وبالتالي فوقف القتال قبل تحقيق
هذه الاهداف سوف يعكس رساله ضعف وهو ما
سيشجع اعدائنا انهم
بامكانهم ان يقدروا علينا وعلى
غلبتنا وبالتالي لن نتنازل ولن نقبل الا
بنصر ساحق وهو يتطلب القضاء على رؤوس
الارهاب وبنيته التحتيه وقدراته
الاداريه وهذا معناه اعاده
هو او الانتصار الحاسم هو يعني ان يعود
المخطوفين وان تكون غزه منزوعه السلاح
وسيطره اسرائيليه على كل ما يدخل الى قطاع
غزه هذه ايضا الشروط الاساسيه لليوم ما
بعد الحرب اريد ان اؤكد ان اليوم ما بعد
وبعد القضاء على حماس هو اولا واخيرا
الانتصار يتم تحقيقه عندما نكون ملتزمين
ومتحدين وجنود الابطال الذين يضحون
بانفسهم وستكون لنا تحديات وصعوبات كثيره
ولكن بعد المجزره في السابع اكتوبر لا مفر
لنا هذا الامن الذي يجب ان نحققه لشعب
اسرائيل ولمستقبل ولسلام في منطقتنا وانا
التزم هنا امام محاربي وامام العائلات
الكله الذين فقدوا الاغلى وانا التزم
امامهم امام عائلات المخطوفين لن نتوقف
ولن نوقف الحرب قبل اعاده اعزائنا الى
الوطن ولن ننهي الحرب بدون الانتصار
الحاسم معا نحارب وباذن الله معا ننتصر
سيدي رئيس الوزراء صباح اليوم اعلن في
شبكه ان بي سي
الامريكيه ان هناك
اقتراح انك هناك انك لن تكون في فتره ما
بعد
ذلك هي تعني هذه الفتره دوله فلسطينيه
وكيف هو التدخل الامريكي بهذا
الشان الكثير من الجهات السياسيه في
اسرائيل اريد ان اقول لك ما يحدث اليوم
بعد نتنياهو و
اتحدث بشكل مباشر ومن يتحدث عن اليوم بعد
نتنياهو هو يتحدث عن اقامه دوله
فلسطينيه وهذا ما يقولونه اريد ان
اقول اليوم ليس اليوم بعد نتنياهو هذا
اليوم بعد كل معظم مواطني
اسرائيل انا مصمم واقول امرا واضح هذا
النزاع ليس على عدم وجود
دوله فلسطينيه وانما وجود دولتنا الدوله
اليهوديه كل منطقه ننسحب منها ناخذ هناك
ارهاب وهذا ما حدث في جنوب لبنان وايضا في
قطاع غزه وهذا حدث في يهودا والسامره ايضا
وعليه انا اؤكد انه في كل تسويه في
المستقبل دوله اسرائيل يجب ان تعمل بامنيا
في كل المنطقه الغربيه وهذا امر
مهم هذه هذه الحقيقه اقول
لاصدقائنا الامريكيين وايضا منعت المحاوله
فرض علينا امور تضر بمصلحه اسرائيل رئيس
الوزراء يجب ان يكون قادر ان يوقف امام
الاصدقاء ويقولوا لا عندما يتطلب الامر
ويقول نعم عندما يتطلب الامر وهكذا اعمل
وهكذا عملت على مدى سنوات ايضا انا احاول
ان اوسع السلام مع دول عربيه وانا مصمم ان
احقق ذلك واوسع هذا السلام لدول اخرى معا
مع اصدقائنا
الامريكيين سيدي رئيس الوزراء قلت انه يجب
ان نعرف كيف نقول لا لاصدقائنا الجيدين هل
المساعدات الانسانيه لغزه وحماس الذي يجب
ان نقول هنا لا من اجل
والسؤال الثاني هو ما يمكن ان تقول ان عدم
اتخاذ قرار وزير الدفاع قال انه عدم اتخاذ
قرار سياسي يضر بالتقدم في العمليه
العسكريه وايضا عم وجود خطه لليوم ما بعد
وايضا بعد الانتصار ما يحدث الان نحن نرى
اننا نخرج من مناطق في غزه هناك
سؤالان ايضا اتبست من وزير
الدفاع فيما يتعلق بالمساعدات الانسانيه
ودخول المساعدات الانسانيه الاقل هناك
اتفاق واضح وهو شرط واضح لمواصله الحرب
لان الانهيار الانساني وانتشار الاوبئه
والجوع هو بشكل كبير سيوقف
القتال عندما نرغب في تحقيق اهداف العرض
يجب ان نعطي
مساعدات الحد الادنى من المساعدات ايضا
بدخول الشاحنات بعدد محدود ايضا فيما
يتعلق باليوم ما
بعد اليوم ما
بعد هو يعني ما بعد حماس ونحن مصممون على
هذا الامر هناك نقاشات كثيره في مجلس
الامن القومي وفي مجلس الحرب يجب ان نواصل
هذا النقاش وشروطنا واضحه وعرضتها وا
القضاء على حماس ايضا تفكيك كامل
ل نزع السلاح في غزه وان يكون هناك اداره
مدنيه لا تدعو الى الارهاب والعمل ضد
اسرائيل هذه الامور المهمه وعندما يتم
وكنت مسرورا عندما يتم تحقيق ذلك الان
يمكن ان نغير النظام يجب ان اقول
انه يجب ان نقوم ب انس
اخذ موافقه دول اخرى فيما يتعلق
بالمساعدات الانسانيه وهذا التاهيل ولكن
انا اشكك في ذلك ان يمكننا ان نقوم ذلك
عندما يستمر وجود حماس وحتى لا تقضي على
حماس سيكون من الصعوب البدايه في هذه
العمليه ما بعد ما بعد الحرب ونحن نعمل
على هذه العمليه ولكن ايضا هذا شرط وايضا
لا اذكر اي حرب في اسرائيل
التي قلنا ان تحققنا فيها انتصارات بدون
ان يكون لدينا خطه لليوم ما بعد وايضا
انتصرنا ويجب ان ننتصر اولا هنا ايضا وفي
النقاشات ايضا هذا
يتم سيدي رئيس الوزراء لم
تدفي ق على حماس ولم تقضوا على السلطه
الفلسطينيه هل هذا بعد طلب من الاداره
الامريكيه وسؤال اخر كيف لماذا ابعدت وزير
الدفاع ورؤساء الاجهزه الامنيه فيما يتعلق
بنقل الادويه الى غزه انت تعتمد على وزير
الدفاع السؤال الاول كان لم نحقق
الاهداف
يجب ان نستمر في الحرب ونواصل في الحرب
وايضا انا لا يمكنن ان اقوم بذلك لدينا
التزامات لمواطني اسرائيل ومن اجل ان نضمن
ان لا يعود ما حدث وايضا ان ننهي المهمه
بانهاء القرب فيما يتعلق بالسؤال الثاني
هذا ايضا اكاذيب كما كم من الاكاذيب يمكن
ان ندخل في يوم واحد
قلت ابعدت وزير الدفاع
نعم اربعه ايام قبل نقل الادويه في ال الث
عشر من الشهر ارسل رئيس الموساد في ايضا
اعرض هذا الامر على مجلس الحرب ارسله
وايضا لوزير الدفاع وايضا لسان
الون الذي يمثل الجيش وايضا لرئيس الشباك
وايضا يحدد كل الاطار لذلك لم يكن ابعاد
وهذا وهذا كذب
وايضا هذا ليس صحيح
فوافقت على ان اعطي الادويه فقط ان تكون
هذه الادويه للمخطوفين ايضا والامر الاخر
الكذب الاخر هو انني وافقت على
ادخال الاغذيه بدون ف الادويه بدون فقص
وهذا امر غير صح
عندما سمعت ان هذا الامر محه الامر ايضا
وجهت واخذت المسؤوليه وقلت انه يجب ان
يكون فحص وعندما حتى لو رفض حماس انا لا
اغير هذه هذا التوجيه الدائم لا شاحنه
تدخل الى غزه بدون فحص الامر الاخر يجب
فيما يتعلق
بتوزيع كم
كيف لم يكن الصليب الاحمر بهذه المهمه
الصليب الاحمر لم يتعاون في هذه
المهمه ايضا تحدثت مع رئيسه الصليب الاحمر
واوضحت لها وايضا اخذنا الادويه عن طريق
الوسيط الوسيط القطري الذي التزم بان
تصل هكذا قال ان تصل هذه الادويه الى
المخطوفين الذين هم بحاجه اليها وانا
اعتقد انه يجب الالتزام بهذا الالتزام
وايضا وكان هناك تراجع فيه ليس في
الاطار سيد رئيس الوزراء سؤال
شخصي
الجمهور يجب انا لا اسئلك حول لجان
التحقيق سؤال
شخصي هل تقول لنفسك وانت تتراجع عن خطا
وتشارك الجمهور فيه عند امور حدثت في
السابع قبل السابع من اكتوبر وايضا بوقت
كب بعد السب من اكتبر انت بينك وبين نفسك
عن خطا ايضا ان بقيه القيادات هي المسؤوله
ويمكن ان يكون سؤال
اخر ان تتحدث ان الحرب ستستمر لوقت طويل
وايضا رؤساء الاجهزه الامنيه وايضا هذه
السنه يمكن ان تشهد في في محكمتك كيف هذه
الامور الطريقه التي سالت به السؤال ايضا
ايضا هذه تمهد وان يقول انا استمع اليك وا
اسمع اليك وانا اريد ان اقول لك شيء اخر
لا لا يوجد شخص لا يخطئ وهذا امر اعتقد
قلت اكثر من مره ان انه هذه الامور تفحص
في الاستديوهات يوميا انا اتحدث عليك انتم
انتم وانا اواصل الحرب مع حماس وانت تواصل
دي وهذه الاسئله من خلال اسئلتك
ايض قلت لك لا هناك هناك
اخطاء انت تريد ان تستمر في الحديث وانا
استمع
شكرا فيما
يتعلق كما تعرف حتى
اليوم
لم يكن اي
مشكله محامي يعالجون المحكمه هذا
يستمر سيدي رئيس الوزراء لماذا اسرائيل لا
يمكن لا تعمل ضد ايران في وان تقاتل راس
الافعى ايران وفيما يتعلق بال انها تصل
ايران الى الحد النووي كيف نتاكد ان
الادويه وصلت الى المخطوفين اللي فيما
يتعلق بالسؤال الثاني اجبته
و ايضا فيما يتعلق بالوسيط ونحن نعرف من
الوسيط بوصول الادويه وانا ايضا اتوقع من
الوسيط ان يلتزم بما تم الاتفاق عليه في
ادخال الادويه وبدون ادخال الادويه بدا
ادخال الادويه هذا الالتزام وهذه الرافعه
اريد ان اقول هناك احتمال ان تصل هذه
الادويه وسنعرف ذلك وايضا عند وصولها الى
الهدف فيما يتعلق
بايران
قلت هناك اجابه من يقول اننا لا نهاجم
ايران نحن نهاجم ايران ايران راس الافعى
وكما ترى من الحوثيين وحزب الله ايران تقف
وراء هذه الجمات نعرف ان هناك نضال ضد
ايران اليوم نفهم
اكثر تحاول ان تعمل ضدنا وتصوروا ما ايران
يمكن ان تعمل في الشرق الاوسط ايضا ان
تقضي على الانظمه وايضا ان تسيطر على
الممرات الدوليه وتصور ان ايران تقوم بذلك
وكم من المهم ان نوقفها وايضا نحن منعنا
حكمات حكومات برئاسته في سنوات جيده
ومنعنا ذلك و ايضا هناك عده مراحل سنمر
بها وانا ملتزم كرئيس وزراء لاسرائيل ان
اعمل كل شيء من اجل ان لا تحصل ايران على
سلاح نووي ليس من اجل وجودنا وامننا وايضا
من اجل امن العالم
اجمع رئيس الوزراء قلت ان اسرائيل لن
تتنازل عن الانتصار الحاسم على حماس وايضا
سمعنا وزير الدفاع ق يقول ان حماس اصيب
بشكل كبير
وايضا هو فيما يتعلق بالسياسه هناك الحديث
عن الانتخابات هل كيف تدعو ليبرمان ولاب
للانضمام الى
حكومتك هناك مرحلتين في الحرب
واحد القضاء على
الكتائب
وهناك لحماس عده نظم قتاليه وايضا تم
القضاء على 17 كتيبه وايضا هناك
تطهير الميدان وايضا والعمليه الاخرى هي
الاوسع ونحن اعتقد ان كل الجهات وبضمنهم
وزير الدفاع وجيش الدفاع يوقفون على
يوافقون على هذا الاطار وفيما يتعلق
بالانتخابات انا
اسال عند عندما نحن في قمه
الحرب الابطال جنودنا الابطال الذين
يعملون انتم توقفون في وسط الحرب توقف كل
شيء
ونبدا حملات حملات
دعائيه وايضا كل شخص يهاجم الاخر وان يكون
هناك انقسام انقسامات بدون بدلا من
الاتحاد وايضا هؤلاء الناس يقترحون اعتقد
انه يجب الت
الان في تحقيق الانتصار وهناك وقت للسياسه
وفيما يتعلق بانن طرحت اقترحت لليبرمان
ولبيد ان ينضم للحكومه فقط احد الاشخاص في
الليكود الذي يمكن ان يقترح ذلك اعتقد
اننا يجب ان نواصل في هذا الائتلاف وهو
ائتلاف صامد وايضا ان نواصل العمل ضمن
حكومه الوحده واعتقد ان الذهاب للانتخابات
هو عدم مسؤول
واض سيضر بالجهود القتاليه والحربيه ومن
يدعو الى ذلك وايضا كل الامور التي نسمعها
في الاستديوهات
وايضا ايران تقف ايضا لن نعطي ايران هذا
الامر ونحن سنحقق الانتصار الحاسم
وشكرا